I mean this is a terrorist attack they
went to a music festival and started
killing people so I get what you're
saying like they are definitely the
under underdogs and stuff but like to
classify it to try and point out that
it's or to make it to legitimize it as a
as an actual military operation I think
totally glosses over the fact that they
attacked civilians
intentionally they did it was a military
operation and Israel is now attacking
civilians intentionally they're not
targeting targeting Isel has a doctrine
of targeting civilians intentionally
it's called the Doctrine and I can lay
out what it is but they believe that if
they attack civilians and humiliate them
they will overthrow they will eventually
rise up against their government they
tested it against Hezbollah and Lebanon
and it failed it's called and it's and
it's being used against the civilians in
the Gaza Strip they want to lower their
morale so much that they actually turn
but you're still talking about a you're
talking about a retaliation right like
CU like I said again this initially
started and and granted you you I I
don't know the the details about about
where they if they attack the uh the
military bases or whatever and I'm not
trying to push back on that but the idea
that this is just a military operation
they specifically went and started
killing people at the festival like I I
mean this it has all of the the it
reminds me of the bodon in Paris like
it's a terror attack the point is to
like so maybe if you want to say that
the Israelis are terrorists as well fine
like I'm I'm not here to defend Israel
but the idea that the initial attack was
a military operation or exclusively
military uh-uh they attacked people and
they went after civilians and killed
people at a at a show when when Max
started to bring this up I mean my I'm
I'm not injecting because I want to hear
what you have to say about what were
they targeting in terms of military
targets I don't think it makes sense for
Hamas to come in and just literally only
target a music festival obviously I
think it's it's reasonable that they
targeted a wide breadth of of things but
uh I do agree with Phil I mean the
problem is the one of the arguments
we're hearing is that they're breaking
out of an open air prison well okay
absolutely I mean I I I know people who
are the families of those in Palestine
those who have come from Gaza and
absolutely have heard these arguments
but to then see them going to music F
like a music festival and laughing about
it you know and and and grabbing people
and throwing them on the ground we I
mean I suppose the argument is the
videos are all fake or something but
there's videos of the guys walking up to
cars and just shooting regular people
like just in their cars who have no idea
what's going on what's that Israeli
doctrine of targeting civilians called
theia Doctrine and they also if you
could if you look up Israel and mowing
the lawn that's a common term that the
Israeli military uses that ain't just
the Israeli military blood makes the
grass gr homie no no but we but I I I
brought this up before when uh um I
think I brought this up when I was on
pbd on Saturday when this all went down
back when protective Edge happened in
2014 I I did not cover uh this stuff
mine mine was civil unrest not Civil War
not not war but uh speaking with many of
the journalists who had covered the
region both in Israel and in pal and
these guys I got to tell you if you met
them you'd be like they're they're
middle of the road milk toast fenet are
types they they refer to it as mowing
the lawn they say Israel every couple of
years will decimate parts of Gaza to
reduce you know uh uh as they described
it their military capabilities but I'm
curious what you know if you want to
elaborate on that yeah I mean there's
there there's so many issues on the
table I mean to the music festival which
is like the the most you know Grizzly
thing one of the most Grizzly things
we've seen prior to Israel leveling
entire neighborhoods in Gaza City
including neighborhoods I stayed in
where many people actually are not
friendly to Hamas um they're holding an
EDM Molly field Music Festival on the B
the drugs that they that they're on are
do not matter it doesn't matter that
they're doing okay okay it doesn't
matter what drugs they're on you're
right what matters is they're holding a
music festival on the border of a caged
in ghetto where people are have very
little water they bathe in salt water in
Gaza I've done it they bathe in
saltwater they have 2 to three hours of
electricity and they're doing this right
there right next to a military base and
what appears to have happened is a
military base was targeted these this
this music festival became a target of
opportunity which is you know
unfortunate and maybe gut-wrenching
there's no way to justify it and here's
what the objective of these figh one of
the main objectives which is not really
discussed properly in our media and it
doesn't matter you support Israel or
Palestine here you have to acknowledge
this objective it's to get as many
Israeli citizens into the hands of the
authorities in Gaza to negotiate because
Israel is holding thousands and
thousands of Palestinian captives in its
prison there is one guy named had anad
who died this this may after a three
Monon three-month hunger strike so
you're you you just said that you said
the goal is to kidnap spur negotiations
and change the strategic by kidnapping
and bringing them back to Gaza that's
kidnapping that's terrorist activity
that fact isra I have watched Israel
kidnap children from their B occupied
Villages no it's not it's not about this
is not about right or wrong it's about
not being not seeing this in a stupid
emotional way I'm not saying you're
being stupid or emotional but we are
being cultivated in this country to be
stupid and emotional by not trying to
understand why this attack took place
gilad Shalit was an Israeli soldier who
is captured out of his tank in 2011 by
fighters from Gaza actually not
affiliated with Hamas and Israel was
forced to exchange over 1,000
Palestinian prisoners captives in the
mind of Palestinians for this one
soldier so now they have let's say a 100
captives they do not want them to die in
Gaza because this is the only bargaining
chip they've had after Palestinians have
had every single diplomatic Channel
blocked to them and they are even
they've even had food channels blocked
to them people people want us to take
the most emotional approach to this
they're killing civilians and stuff I
think I think you know that's typically
my view it's bad that they're doing that
I agree with Phil but I do think it's
absolutely Fair uh to step back and say
why are they doing it how do they view
it and and and to do that involves some
very ruthless well kidnapp exactly
kidnapping civilians which they've
explicitly said they will now execute
unless Israel takes specific specific
actions like no more bombings the they
said warn they said warn before bombing
because Israel's been bringing roofs
down on the heads of entire families a
family of 19 was killed in in jabalia
refugee camp that's what they said they
didn't the but the Palestinians didn't
warn the Israelis that they were coming
to the festival right they didn't warn
Israelis that they were the festival was
the target you they weren't warning they
weren't warning people they weren't
warning the Israelis that they were
coming so you're pointing out that the
Israelis do warn the Palestinians like
hey this location we are going to blow
it up yeah like I do I I correct
correctly if I'm wrong I think uh uh the
alasan brigades warned ashalon that they
were going to be firing a bunch of
rockets ashalon I think yes they did
they should these areas are now mostly
evacuated but uh you know I've done
interviews in Gaza just like we're doing
now although maybe without the malort
and I went up in Palestine Tower to do
an interview in the middle of Gaza City
I walked up nine flights of stairs
because the electricity was off
everything's running on generators there
um and did some interviews few years
later Israel drops a warning flare on
the roof of that media tower where all
the journalists work and operate I've
also edited videos from there with some
really nice Palestinian journalists just
cool people you would all like to hang
out with who would love to leave their
little strip of land and can't anyway
and then Israel brings the whole Tower
down there's video of it so it's okay
they warn it but why are they bringing
down residential and office Towers while
everyone is silent and allegedly because
there's
Hamas that building I mean well you
asked the reason so that's the reason
they say at least so well this this this
is the challenge for those that are not
involved right I I'm I'm anti-war I
think us involvement in in 99% of things
is their lies I mean I grew up on this
stuff right all all the lies to get us
to what put military bases surrounding
Iran uh John Bolton saying by this time
next year we'll be celebrating inan it's
it's blood lust so when I look at
something like Israel the challenge for
me is I'm not nearly as involved as you
and I'm not nearly as zealous as many of
like the neoconservatives and the more
conservative base so when Rockets come
flying from uh uh from Gaza and start
blowing up over Tel Aviv I this was huge
right this was like 2014 when the
Rockets first started reaching Tel Aviv
was that cuz I remember uh I had a
friend in Tel Aviv I was there at that
time yeah mess messaged me freaking out
on Facebook book that a rocket exploded
over her house and this has never
happened before and she do know what to
do and and I'm like man this is horror
it's horror it's War it's terrifying how
do we stop this and so what ends up
happening is every time I've engaged
with it again not an expert on this
stuff I mean I prob might know a little
bit more than the average person but
it's like I appreciate your perspective
I'm glad you're here to tell us about
this stuff too uh because I think only
talking to people who are on the more
pral side is going to leave us you know
blind to the arguments from the other
side but I hear Israel they're they're
they're using hospitals and school R in
civilian areas to launch rockets from
knowing that it will make it extremely
difficult for Israel to stop the rocket
fire into civilian areas then I hear the
same thing but a media tower was taken
down for what purpose why is Israel
targeting this and every time I hear
this my my Med commun I fall right back
to This Is War and in in war the ru
there's no rules rules are for in my
it's like this idea of war crimes I
always find so silly like obviously we
think some things are so egregious that
even in war they're a crime but yo the
people who win those Wars don't care
what you think because you're gone and
so when I look at what's going on in
Israel and Palestine I know that you've
got two factions that are going to use
whatever arguments whatever whatever
psychological warfare whatever physical
Warfare they can to try and win this and
I know that there probably is a right a
right side and someone tell the truth
and I know for a fact there's an
objective truth and and lies to what's
going on I don't know how to navigate
that well just two points on that I mean
there's this issue of human Shields like
Biden said Palestinians are human
Shields that's a way of basically saying
there are no civilians there at all
and the Gaza Strip is one of the most
densely populated places on milon people
there's like it's 2 million people Jam
why are they there by the way that most
of them are refugees and they have to be
there because they're not Jewish they
can't go back to the land of their
families pre pre 1948 they keep having
kids they're being Warehouse there they
Surplus Humanity so it's like the logic
of a prison and so everybody there is a
human shield but there was a place I I
like to eat cuz it was real cheap in in
Tel Aviv that was right next to the um
defense Ministry called hakira and the
all the generals would be in there the
intelligence Chiefs good Mediterranean
food are they human Shields is is that
is building this giant Tower in the
middle of a residential area in Tel Aviv
are they making those people human
Shields if that gets hit by Hezbollah
and people die nearby were they being
used by Israel as human Shields no one
will say that because the logic is so
discriminatory towards Palestinians no
one will consider their position and
then the other point I wanted to make is
just about the use of violence in this
conflict by Palestinians who have tried
everything I mean I don't know if you
know about what the the great March of
return was was sanctioned by Hamas but
it was a Grassroots initiative in Gaza
to just March without weapons like guns
to the wall that surrounds them and they
were shot one by one in the legs many of
them were killed uh journalists were
killed covering it it was a complete
bloodb
and that's when the society said you
know what we can't win with this tactic
of you know walking to the fence and
just asking them to let us in they don't
want us that's that's and and so and
everyone and and you know no one
everyone ignored that and now they're
paying attention to the violence in Gaza
used to have 9,000 settlers in it 9,000
settlers who took like 30 to 40% of the
water in a place of 1.5 million people
why did those settlers leave it was
because of the second intifa it was
because of the violence that was applied
and much more gruesome violence in many
ways than we're seeing now because this
was the time of suicide bombings um
people willing to die because they were
so desperate blowing themselves up in
order to kill because they had no
weapons at that point now the the
factions in Gaza actually have reverse
engineered Israel's military and they
have weapons so they don't need to do
suicide bombing so Gaza did
that Hamas did that then what is the
West Bank right now it's controlled by
the Palestinian Authority which is
funded partly through the EU and state
department they don't resist Israel in
fact they arrest Palestinians on behalf
of Israel and what do Palestinians have
there in many ways they have the same
prison style situation as they have in
Gaza but with settlers all around them
so what does that tell Palestinians it
tells them the only way to get this off
our back is through violence is are
there Palestinians who live in Israel
yes in like Tel Aviv and all that are
they uh well they live in mostly in an
area South called Jaffa or yafa but I
mean like somebody who is of Palestinian
they're 1.5 million Palestinian citizens
of Israel and they're said to have equal
rights but there are discriminatory laws
on the books yeah mosqu right there's
like 400 mosques within Israel right
yeah I mean the mosques op um operate I
mean there's pressure on them to like
shut off the mine at night and you know
there's all kinds of like personal like
individual conflicts or cultural
conflicts taking place but yes there are
Palestinian citizens what's the
solution I mean it's like the
generational question that nobody has
the answer to offer Palestine to become
the 51st state of the UN States come on
let's let's let's I'm getting 100%
serious okay but that's that's not
that's not where is see Palestine is not
a state it can be and no Hawaii Hawaii
can be a
state thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net